hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2015 live from
the LA Convention Center right here and
as such it is California and the Irish
have taken over the pride of Waterford
Ireland jean-marie waterford it is yes
specifically exactly we're representing
right here on their on the game spot
stage hello sir how are you doing yeah
that's too bad are you I'm not - I'm
doing all right I'm feeling pretty
apparently on fresh face the corner crew
face you want the other hand you make me
feel tired because I just I suddenly
feel tired you're sporting your
development beard yeah so whenever we
see you with a beard it means you've
been just sitting down hammering a
keyboard for for six months we met at
the PlayStation experience back in
December I guess it was and since then
you guys have kind of like done a media
sort of black at almost you're kind of
just in like development mode what was
the reasoning behind that well I just
like I dropped off Twitter things like
that which doesn't sound like a big deal
I was the biggest Twitter user anyway
yeah I just kind of read post anything
we did we turned out loads of press it's
done like there was just loads of
interest around the game and we could
actually have done press yeah every day
and then just don't get any of the game
done and so that was one reason just
wanted to get our heads down another
reason was I suppose a lot of people
said there was a lot of like hype around
the game beer and that's a weird feeling
as a developer actually you'd think it
would be a good thing and because like
you want people to be excited about you
Gabe you know and it's a double-edged
sword because their expectations are
kind of almost getting out of your hand
I guess it's a scary thing yeah but then
I suppose probably a bigger thing was I
just said personally I just didn't want
yeah I wasn't getting anything from it I
didn't want to do any press you know and
I we were booked to go to like GDC and
dice and stuff like that and do talks
and I just said like to the rest of the
guys you can do it but I just don't want
to I suppose just a really personal
level it sounds really selfish like I
just don't a joyous so what's it been
like then for six
once being able to sort of concentrate
on your baby and not worry about the
distractions and has no man sky changed
in any way in its direction in the past
six months I think like III for us now
is showing like that we think is really
coming together you know I was actually
going to say that on stage they said
don't say that sounds bad like you know
but that's what it felt like for me you
know we showed videos before and those
videos were a fair reflection you know
but I don't think people realize how
impressive it is to be able to just
stand there and pick any star at random
and just go there and say it might not
be perfect but like I'm happy enough to
show this kind of thing I guess there's
a I think for some of the other demos as
impressive as they are like nobody's
kind of scrutinized most games don't get
scrutinized to the level that no man sky
has been because I think there was this
impression that there's a smoke and
mirrors aspect to it so yeah kind of a
ballsy move to go on the Sony conference
and then just pick a random level and
see what's ended up being there well we
want it like a lot of you know the hype
thing is like we could have done a very
staged demo yeah but all I felt that
would do is like increase hype you know
and I wanted to just show something
there was more real so like to me that
demo was sort of like sort of boring
because basically just pick a platter
did you go that you land and like you go
up to a beacon and you know almost you
could see do it even though like do
whether it was over yeah you didn't seem
like you know it was like I guess we
stopped there back away from it like
about it as opposed to showing like five
minutes of space bottles and yeah well
like I was joking before today about
like every every dev oh pretty much out
all the conferences so far 50% of them
end with like a monster coming out
screaming you know and then it cuts your
fade to black and you're with three fish
uploading some core
excited sounds pretty bad when you put
it like that yeah add a kind of a and
we'll leave it there right so what else
could have happened what was in like all
the other universes we live in you know
all the other universes that exist so we
can see we saw the things it rehearsal
like you know where I would land I was
hoping that I would land and there would
be lots of creatures there yeah and then
I could talk about that a bit the backup
to that was like if there's nothing
there there's a bored barren planet I'll
just like mind some resources yeah sure
that the planet is destructible and
stuff and so that was kind of what we
went with and like you know you just
have to kind of roll with it the ideal
is like the you do land and there's some
crazy big creature or something like
that there and you can kind of show that
off kind of like that huge dinosaur you
saw in like previous e3 demo but then if
that happened probably ever would have
said it was staged so yeah at the start
there was that really sort of cool
spaceship battle like we're seeing a lot
of new new footage here as well actually
which is which is fantastic and yeah
that big space battle and you get you
said like you could pick which side to
take in that battle like just wondering
about those sort of situations like I
play lots of games like elite dangerous
and we're like that sort of stuff is
you've you've chosen already like in
what in that situation are you just
picking who did a battle with based on
just what's happening or I do have
allegiances with specific parties yeah
like we're nothing like GTA yeah right
but it's the easiest way I have to
explain it like you know how if you play
GTA and you go to a rival gangs region
they'll instantly just start attacking
you yeah you know if you start attacking
some pedestrians then the police will
have a reaction you know and so we have
a similar kind of system people might
have noticed it that there is like a
wanted level up in the top right-hand
corner and so if you start attacking
innocent so you start attacking traders
or freighters then the police will have
a reaction to that and start chasing you
and if you attack police they were just
on patrol or military then similar thing
will happen
and with regards to factions there
battling anyway that goes on whether
you're there or not you could just
choose to join in if you attack one
particular faction then they're gonna
remember that and they might shoot first
next time if you decide to instead kind
of protect freighters from like pirates
and things like that presumably you
could like have a mission to like help
them get through perhaps or but it's not
really mission yeah it's like if you
imagine if you imagine GTA but you don't
do any of the missions and you just
interact with the world that's kind of
what we're after like a an action
sandbox yeah is that what no man sky
essentially is it's almost like because
the thing is when we talk to you about
these games like you you're it's almost
like a reticence to try and explain them
but I guess if it's a action sandbox
then by explaining it you're kind of
ruining the fun like do you want people
to get into no man's sky and kind of not
know what the rules of this world yeah
absolutely like and the more we do these
shows the boat we probably ruin it for
people like but you know we're trying to
hold a little bit back at least or I
don't know not trying not to over
explain it like minecraft like yeah did
the coolest thing about minecraft was
that they didn't tell you you know what
the crafting recipes were and I don't
know whether I would have had the nerve
for that to release the game without
doing that but it's so it's so cool you
know and some people will just go and
create wiki's and and you know some
people will go and read wiki's and some
people just want to find out for
themselves and we have similar kind of
elements we actually have crafting in
the game as well and you know we have
like these ways that you interact like
I'm talking about police or military
even things like that aren't made super
obvious to you you just see how they're
interacting and you follow it from there
kind of thing presumably you're just
like creating this sandbox and then
looking forward to when people get to
play themselves they'll that information
will propagate and that way idea all the
systems have to work and create like
nice game loops kind of like so many
games particularly on PC at the moment
like and say like stranded deep or
assault or
you know terraria star those kind of
games like have have that system where
they just have here is a set of rules
here's the world go out and played how
you want and it's you know it is very
different and it confuses people up is
and you know and it is hard to talk
about a game like that before it comes
out normally those games just come out
yeah you know they're found on early
access and people figure them out as
they go along and then the media picks
up once there's been pause exactly what
you guys have to unfortunately go
through appears we can't complain though
really you know like it's lovely that
people are interested in the game and it
fires us up to make it you know when I'm
saying I don't want to do press it's not
it's not because we aren't happy that
people are excited about the cave of
course we are you know well it's a yeah
like that's a continuing sort of problem
with games coverage as well I saw a
really good talk at GDC a couple years
ago about that from the guys who made
frog fractions oh yeah trying to keep
wonder because when we grew up you know
playing Commodore games like yeah you
hurt you'd like in mortal combat you're
wondering like somebody said oh if you
do such and such like spider-man turns
up and like who knows it's like maybe at
one of the areas of everybody talked
about last year when we did the video
series on GameSpot and was how this
world how its one big world and
obviously like you probably don't want
to get into the nitty-gritty of that
either but like the idea that you could
find this planet and then yeah somebody
else might run into it like now if
everyone's gonna be looking for the ìiî
planet but this is a world where you can
play with others but is it sort of
you're playing with them in that you're
noticing where they've been rather then
you're like actually I love dog fighting
alongside other yeah like we were very
careful about saying that like this is
not if you're expecting a you know a
deathmatch game yeah or an MMO know what
this is you know and it's like journey
you know journey has a lovely
multiplayer component to us but you
would never say journeys yeah let's all
sit down on Friday with a few beers and
play journey it's just not that kind of
game and that's that would be the same
for no man sky you know and it's
interesting when we talked last year as
well it seemed like you really had a
strong idea here's you wondering if you
should finish the demo or not it seemed
like you had a really
strong identity of what the game was has
that changed in the past 12 months no I
I I'm like really proud of the guys that
we haven't done that they're like all
this you know interest at - things like
that we've just kind of kept focused and
that's that's why like people somebody
said to me like you know it's like three
years since you were outside game what
are you gonna release it like oh it's
about a year - huh we've only showed it
like we showed us the first time bgx
then III then kind of PSX and now again
you know where's most games you know
that from the kind of CLU you're seeing
them at every like at every party we see
yeah but you made of events there are
now yeah you've actually skipped quite a
lot of them yeah yeah we showed Joe
danger way more no one paid any
attention
oh hey citizen game pay detain you guys
take it yeah yeah no uh like I was
saying it to grad who I work with and
just before III before the press
conference there was like screenshots
new screenshots from Noah's sky leaked
and a wet old odd all the websites and I
was like where were these guys for Joe
Hey Joe you know whatever leaked to Joe
Daedra screenshots
you need a fake you can make some fake
reddit account just start pumping them
out there
come on somebody pick up yeah yeah
guerrilla journalism inside of the games
industry so we can't complain about that
like that makes it way easier we're -
you know on the show floor just trying
to drum people in and stuff and that
allows us to actually focus on
development and we need to cuz we're big
insane in the type of game that would
yeah we didn't try and make something
small and it always seemed like it was
it was it was gonna take a while yeah
but like you don't have a release date
for this like it's obviously not coming
out this year do you know when it's
gonna be like are we talking 2016 early
lays do you have any idea so we're not
saying year and things like that we
really wanted to really like announce a
release date and and like it's really
hard to explain like most people will
think they're used to somebody much more
important sitting here talking about a
bunch more report Gabe at there
say you know they'll have a real clever
press plan yeah you know um like we we
want the game to be out you don't like
if it was if we thought it was good
enough yeah we would release it if we
thought it was finished we would release
it you know we just have to make sure
that it is we were going to announce a
release date there's reasons why we
began to realize that it might not be
accurate okay some reasons outside of
our control and I just don't want the
pressure of that to be honest like it's
like what I would create by you know you
actually create people being upset with
you yeah you know for announce your
release date and then changing it it's
the worst thing it's like saying
Christmas is the 25th of December and
then changing it's like you know
actually no we'll leave we'll have
Christmas a little bit later this year
you know you can't say that to be an
airshow because now I'm like oh well it
could be out this year I guess if you're
gonna say it that way
and I've already got The Witcher and
bloody fall air force now apparently
coming out the problem is I have the
Witcher it's still don't open it where's
Alex yeah don't let Sean open The
Witcher don't let him play fallout 4 we
need to get no man skies some stage and
so I'm guessing whenever it whenever
really you're closer to release date
you'll probably talk about it then are
you gonna be shopping it around for the
rest of the year you're gonna be a
Gamescom you're gonna go to the knee of
the paksas and I'm like personally just
gonna try and limit it as much as
humanly possible I know that sounds bad
again but like I don't think I don't
think it actually does anyone any good
you know like as in you know if if
people are excited about the game and
they tell me I actually feel bad I just
feel like you know like you've a wave on
your shoulders almost well it's not out
yet and it's like get excited about it
what is house you know is that bad to
say like you know you want people to
know about the game and stuff and so
that is important to do this kind of
thing but right now we feel we probably
have what we need in that we have people
who will at least read a review and see
whether the game is any good
you know and if we've got that then
we're kind of happy enough and we just
need to deliver it for me
awesome last question because I know
you're very very busy man and it must
have been cool to be able to go on the
PC gaming show and say yeah you know
what this is actually common air for PC
as well yeah that was really nice you
know it's to think we've known for a
while and like Sony have been really
supportive of it actually you know which
is which is nice I mean you can see that
with a bunch of other games that they're
doing with Street Fighter it's so far
yeah and and we always assumed it would
be a problem but actually they've been
quite good about it you know I do you
know whether or not like it'll be day
and Dave on both platforms as as close
as we possibly can you know awesome Sean
Murray pleasure as ever to talk to you
my friends best of luck with the rest of
development don't touch any I know
2015's ended up actually being a pretty
solid year for game releases don't play
anything else we need to get no man
Scott I feel bad you feel bad for me
yeah I feel bad for thanks so much for
coming on really appreciate it's a lot
done a gamespot stage continues right
here at e3 2015 let us know what you
think about no man's sky in the comment
box below and we'd be back in a minute
but more video games